after no winter on Monday the Powerball
jackpot is now at 1.2 billion dollars
the second highest in its 30-year
history Joshua peguero is at the Arizona
last stop about 60 miles Southeast of
Las Vegas and about 30 miles from the
Hoover Dam he spoke to people waiting in
those long lines for a ticket
1.2 billion dollars is where the
Powerball jackpot currently stands and
we're here at the last stop in Arizona
where I'm joined from gentlemen from
Dallas Texas so as I asked you sir off
camera what's the first thing you would
buy with your winnings go ahead I would
buy each of my children a brand new
house and uh I would pay you know just
pay attention to what God has for me so
I would give 10 of it to the church that
would be the actual first thing I would
do but again each and every one of my
children hey you would get a brand new
house and how many kids you have I have
seven kids seven and where would you buy
these houses in Texas or Las Vegas I
would buy them all over wherever they'd
like to go that's where they would end
up at I'm actually from Dallas so I
would have a house here and also in Las
Vegas all right then you heard it you
would buy a house for seven of his kids
if he was to win that Powerball jackpot
reporting at the last stop in Arizona
Josh pereiro 8 News Now